The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: All right.
Hello people.
Welcome back to the
second week of our course.
I'm happy to have this
wonderful live audience.
But I also would
like very briefly
to address our
video audience, who
will no doubt be watching
this long after I'm
dead on MIT's OpenCourseWare.
So think of this as a
voice from the grave.
You and the video
audience will sometimes
notice that as I'm lecturing
to this lively group,
I will turn this
way and look up.
You should realize that what I'm
turning toward and looking up
at is this projection screen,
which we will show you.
And it sometimes has
this outline on it,
which hopefully guides
us through each lecture
and sometimes has other
information and material on it.
Sometimes it isn't
worth shifting over
to show the video
audience that image.
But that's what I'm looking
at when I look so strange.
I'd like to begin today
by taking a step back,
by reminding you that
the order in which we're
watching the movies
in this course
is a little bit
arbitrary because I
wanted to use the feature
films as the defining date.
And that's the
reason that we made
Keaton come first because The
General is an earlier film.
It was almost a decade
earlier than Modern Times.
But the truth is Chaplin
entered film before Keaton.
And Keaton had
certain advantages
by the time he entered the
movies, in part because
of Chaplin's example,
although also
because of the fairly
complicated way
in which silent film had
already elaborated itself
after the first 10 years
or so of the 20th century.
So I want to take a step
back into that early phase,
just before Chaplain becomes
a filmmaker really in 1911,
I think is when he joins
the Keystone Studios.
Just to remind you of a story
that is told systematically
in David Cook's History
of Narrative Film,
which is part of our required
reading in the course.
And I hope you will
attend especially
to the details Cook offers about
those early years in Hollywood.
If you read those
chapters from Cook
about the early
years of Hollywood
before Chaplin, the
movies before Chaplin,
you'll recall that one of the
most fundamental things that
happens before
Chaplin even appears
is the establishment
essentially of the industry I
was describing last time.
The migration to the West
Coast is worth mentioning.
Because movies, of
course, begin their career
in the United States
on the East Coast.
Edison's first movie studio
was in East Orange, New Jersey.
The Biograph Company
was originally
located on the East Coast.
And almost all the
original earliest
films, even the earliest films
that were put into production
and shown commercially,
were made on the East Coast.
Why did people move
to the West Coast?
Why did Hollywood become
the sort of center
of the movie industry?
What explains it?
It happens very early.
One might think of it as
a very important moment
in the history of culture,
of popular culture,
because for all the changes
that the movie industry has
undergone, Hollywood
remains the kind of center
of what is now a kind of global
enterprise of movie making.
What helps to explain the
move to the West Coast?
Nothing fancy.
In the back, yes.
AUDIENCE: Film year around.
DAVID THORBURN: They could
film the year around.
Why is that important,
especially in the early days?
AUDIENCE: You can
make movies whenever.
You don't have to produce
them in the summer.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes.
You're not as dependent
on the weather.
The Sun always
shines in California.
If it's overcast,
you can still film.
And there's no snow.
There's virtually no rain.
The weather is very conducive
to the making of film.
And especially in
this early phase,
when film stock was
relatively primitive compared
to the complexity
of film stock we
have-- today, the film
stock is so subtle
that you can film in the dark.
You can film by fire light.
Even amateur folks
owning camcorders
can film virtually in the dark.
They can film by electric
light inside a room.
Or tape, they can
videotape in that way.
In the earliest
days of film, you
needed a tremendous amount
of light to expose the film.
And what it meant that you
were dependent on the weather.
So that was one major reason.
But there's another one
that's even more important
in some ways, even though that
would seem a sufficient reason
for explaining why the migration
to the West Coast occurred.
There's another even
more powerful one.
It has to do with the
idea of patent warfare.
Yes.
What's your suggestion?
You don't have to
give the right answer.
Give a--
AUDIENCE: Different types of
terrains fall into those--
DAVID THORBURN: Oh,
that's also true.
Yes.
The environment of
Southern California
is particularly conducive to
a variety of film projects.
There are mountains nearby.
There's ocean nearby.
There's desert nearby.
And, of course,
that's also something
that makes it a uniquely
valuable environment.
Maybe not a unique
environment, but a particularly
valuable environment.
And that's a good answer.
And you're right about that.
But there's something else.
And it has to do with conditions
in the East and Thomas Edison.
Remember, Edison
in a certain way
wanted to lay claim to
virtually every invention
in the early part
of the 20th century.
And he was primed to do so.
He was already recognized
as a great genius,
as the premier entrepreneurial
inventor of his era.
And he immediately,
as he had done
with other projects
of his, began
to take out patents
to try to control
the use of movie technology.
He wanted to become
the Edison monopoly.
He was fantasizing that he would
control the movie-- whatever
the movie industry would
become, Edison's company
fantasized it was going
to take control of that.
And, in fact, the Edison Company
hired law enforcement officers
and, according to
some historians,
even in some places hired
goons, thugs, to go and break up
the sets and the shooting
of rival producers who were,
according to Edison, infringing
on Edison copyrights.
So the other reason-- another
reason for the move to the West
Coast was a lot of the
entrepreneurial movie makers
wanted to get free
of the patent police.
They wanted to get out from
under the scrutiny of Edison
and his police.
And by running to the West
Coast, they were able to do so.
And, in fact, Edison was
unsuccessful in controlling
the technology, as Cook
and other historians
have made clear to us.
So the move to the West Coast
is a very important one.
And I will return to the
cultural, the historical,
and ideological or
intellectual implications
of that move to the West
Coast in a few lectures,
maybe next week if I
get the opportunity.
Because I want to
talk a little bit more
about what it meant
for American movies
that film was made on the
farthest western verge
of the society, away
from cultural centers,
unlike the way in which
movies developed in Europe.
And I'll talk about that
implication a bit later.
Probably next week, when we talk
about the great German silent
film that concludes our
segment on silent films.
So even before Chaplin enters,
the rudiments-- or more
than the rudiments, the basic
system of mass production,
of studio-based
production, of manufacture
of the films in
one place and then
the distribution system that
developed in which theaters
essentially rented or purchased
films from the producers
was already in place.
And, of course, the
two great figures here
is Thomas Ince-- and Cook
writes very well about Ince
and his contribution
to the movies--
probably the person to whom we
could attribute the invention
of the movie studio, I suppose.
And Mack Sennett, who
developed the Keystone Studios,
out of which so many important
early comedies emerged
and the studio
which Chaplin joined
when he came to
the United States
to become a movie maker
in, I think, 1911 or 1912.
So Ince and Mack
Sennett are important.
And one might say one further
thing about this moment.
As you know if you've
read Cook, Sennett
created what came to be
called the Keystone Studios.
And Keystone Studios were
named, I think-- or maybe
it was the reverse.
I'm not sure-- was associated
with their prime product
in the early days.
And they were called the
Keystone Kops Komedies.
We're going to show you a
fragment of those in a moment.
They were frenzied action,
frenzied physical action.
So this is the era.
This is the moment, the
period in the first 10 years
of the movie industry
in the United States,
when the basic system is being,
by trial and error, worked out.
And by the time
Chaplin comes to join
the system after the
first decade or so
of the 20th century, the
system essentially is in place.
There are already a number
of famous performers,
both in comedy and in drama.
There are emerging
certain particular studios
who have refined
the mass production
technique to produce their
movies on a regular basis.
So an expanding
market for the movies
is being met by a systematic
manufacturing process
that Ince and Sennett
begin to work out
in systematic and
long-lasting ways.
In ways that in a
certain sense continue
in residual form,
in vestigial form,
to dominate the production
of movies even today.
When we were talking about the
primitive and the simplicity
of early film, there was
one film I had on the stocks
we didn't have time
to show you last week.
And I thought I would
show this to you
as a way of illustrating
again how relatively simple
the early films are.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
See how influential
that first sneeze was.
The name of this film
is The Whole Dam Family.
There's Mr. Dam.
There Mrs. Helen Dam.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's their son, Jimmy Dam.
The simplicity of
these movements
are part of what's
interesting to us.
I mean this is still an era
in which people are just
fascinated by the idea
that movies capture movies.
But what's the joke here?
The joke is embedded I suppose
in the title, The Whole Dam
Family.
There's Miss.
I.P. Dam.
There's Baby Dam.
What an actor.
You see how it's framed
as if it's a painting, how
stationary the camera is.
There's the Dam Cook.
What's the joke here?
Finally, we're going
to come to the Dam Dog.
What's going on here?
It's kind of risque.
Remember, we're talking
about late Victorian,
post-Victorian era.
What's the joke here?
It's the play on
the word "damn."
It doesn't strike
you as shocking.
But, in fact, if you said,
damn you in 1890 or in 1900
in certain quarters, people
stepped back and said,
oh, my goodness.
There's a kind of
semi-vulgarity there.
In other words,
it's not an accident
that this is not the Thorburn
family or the Smith family.
It's significant that
it's the Dam family.
Why?
Because they want
to make a joke.
What's wrong with the joke?
Why is it a stupid
joke for a movie?
Because it's not a visual joke.
What does it depend on it?
It depends on language.
In other words, it's almost as
if the whole point of this film
depends on a joke that depends
not on anything that you
can experience
visually, but that
is resident in a verbal trick.
And it's a trivial joke.
It's not much of a joke, but
the film depends upon it.
And it's evidence in a very
modest, but at the same time
dramatic and obvious way
of this process whereby
the new medium, this
new visual medium,
has to emerge out of media, some
of which are not visual at all,
but are verbal.
And it's as if early filmmakers
haven't yet learned fully
how to exploit the qualities of
the medium they're working in.
So it's a verbal joke,
rather than a visual joke.
Much more powerful and
much more successful
were the Keystone Kops
Komedies themselves.
And we have one example
of that to show you.
I'm not sure that this is
a characteristic example.
But it's close
enough to give you
as a sort of sense of what
the Keystone Komedies were
like before Chaplin
entered the game.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The essential joke
of the Keystone Kops
Komedies-- I don't even
know how many there were,
perhaps hundreds.
There were certainly
dozens and dozens.
They were immensely
popular early short films.
Some film scholars
have speculated
that one reason for
their popularity
was that they made
fun of policemen.
That was an implicit sort
of mildly anarchic impulse
in these early comedies
because authority figures,
people in uniform,
were being shown
to be clownish in some way.
The primary element,
of course, is
to find ways to exploit
the movies' capacity
to show motion.
And one reason I want you to see
this relatively crude example
is that there's a
certain sense in which
the short film that you saw
last week from Keaton, the film
Cops, is a sort of reprise of
this tradition of movie making.
Although you can see how much
more coherent and character
oriented Keaton's
short film was,
but the way in which especially
the cops are mocked and shown
to be completely
clownish figures.
Almost all of the Keystone
Kops Komedies to my knowledge,
involved incompetent
policeman, who
engaged in mad active chases,
which often ended badly
for the policeman.
Sometimes they would
end up all flying
into a river, or an ocean, or
some other natural disaster.
And I think you can also
see-- that was actually
a very dramatic effect
for an early film.
So there's an awful
lot about this
that would have
interested early--
seeing that car turn over,
some people in the audience
might never have seen
that in the movies before.
And one could say that
these films in a certain way
anticipate a great deal of the
ridiculous action adventure
activity that we see
in films even today.
But this is typical of those
early films, where they'll
make incredibly implausible
jokes just for the sake
of making the joke.
And I'm not sure-- all
right, a Mack Sennett comedy.
This is the kind
of comedy then that
was being made by the Sennett
Studio before Chaplain arrived.
They were also certain
figures-- Fatty Arbuckle,
the fat comedian who worked with
Buster Keaton, is an example.
Who had already begun to
establish comic personae,
something like the persona that
Chaplin and Keaton created.
So they were not the
first to do this.
So there was a subtler
and already somewhat more
character-oriented
comedy beginning
to emerge before
Chaplin appears.
But Chaplin's entry
into American movies
is also a turning point, a
fundamental turning point,
as many scholars
have recognized.
And it's a turning
point primarily
because what Chaplin
introduces-- I mean
introduces many, many
things to comedy.
But he introduces one
thing especially-- well,
two things especially.
The first thing
that he introduces
is what we might call the
principal of the slow down.
Instead of frenzied motion all
the time in Chaplin comedies,
there are moments of quiet.
And in these moments
of quiet-- and this
is why they're important--
what begins to happen
is an attention is thrown away
from violent, frenzied physical
action toward character.
What Chaplin
introduces into movies
is a somewhat more systematic
and serious interesting
character than had
ever occurred before.
And what follows from
that introduction,
from slowing down
the action, creating
moments of human interaction
in which the interest is
essentially psychological
and individual,
rather than an interest simply
in frenzied motion and jokes,
or frenzied motion
and suspense, which
is what you would get from a
Griffith melodrama, what you're
getting is-- so this
introduces several things.
First of all, it introduces
a tonal variation.
It means that in the
middle of comedies,
there could be quiet,
serious moments.
And, in fact, it becomes the
hallmark of Chaplin's comedy
that it really is
often not funny
or at least that it's
based on unfunny materials.
And that there are poignant
and moving moments.
It's as if Chaplin combines
comic and melodramatic
elements, especially
in his best work.
I don't mean that when
he came into the films
he began to do this.
In fact, he discovered
how to do this
in the course of his
career, about which I
will speak in a moment.
So Chaplin brings a new
interest in character
and in psychological nuance.
And, because of that
introduces tonal variation,
a complexity of tone.
We think of the Tramp
figure as indelible
and unchanging in a certain way.
His costume always the same,
his face always the same,
the kinds of problems he
gets into always similar.
And that's partly true.
But the Tramp was not born fully
dressed in Chaplin's brain.
He evolved the
Champ over a series
of short films in
the period from 1911
through about 1913 or '14.
And one way I can
dramatize this for you
is to show you how Charlie
looked in the very first film
he appeared in.
He was not a director
in this film.
He was just an actor.
And he was a walk-on actor.
He was not the star.
The camera had an
immediate affinity for him.
And after people
saw this film-- this
is the first film
he appeared in.
This is a still
from a film called
Kid Auto Races at Venice.
It's a kind of documentary
about soapbox racing.
And the Chaplain character had
just been hired by Mack Sennett
to join the Keystone Studios.
And he made an
appearance in the film.
He really didn't
have anything to do.
But his appearance in the film
caused all kinds of interest
in the audience.
The audience wanted to know
who that character was,
why he was so interesting, and
what was interesting about him.
You can see the beginnings
of the Tramp costume there,
but not the complete Tramp.
Here's another early version
of Chaplin, wearing a long coat
and not looking very nice.
Charlie is supposed to
be drunk in this picture.
That's one reason
he looks nasty.
It's in a film called
Mabel's Married Life.
And he's actually
in conversation
with a dummy in this sequence.
But you can see here that
the long coat violates
our idea of who the Tramp was.
So it took awhile before the
Chaplain persona completely
emerged.
And it was partly a
matter of trial and error,
although very quick
trial and error.
I want to say a word
about Chaplin's career,
to give you a fuller sense of
how swiftly he became an icon
and how significant
his example is
for our understanding
of the power of movies.
Chaplain's dates
are 1889 to 1977.
He was born in England.
And his early
childhood is actually
the stuff of
Dickensian melodrama,
both terms I choose
with some intentionality
because there are parallels
between Charlie Chaplin's
early life and the
victimization that Dickens
dramatizes so powerfully in
many of his famous novels.
And there are parallels
between Dickens' own childhood
and Chaplain's childhood.
Dickens, the great
19th century novelist,
who, like Chaplin, was
interested in victims,
laid emphasis on the problems
of vulnerable people,
of women, of children,
who wrote variations
on what we might call the
mortgage melodrama all
his career.
His greatest works could be
said to be forms of melodrama.
I'm talking about Charles
Dickens, the great 19th century
English novelist.
And Chaplin grew up in an
environment that was steeped,
not only in Dickens, but
in the traditions of stage
and novelistic
melodrama that permeated
European culture and especially
English culture of this time.
But his life was a very
difficult one in some ways
as well.
His father died
when he was eight.
His mother was in and out of the
institutions all of her life.
There were periods in Chaplin's
life, when he was just
a little child, when he was
literally completely abandoned.
And he and his older brother
spent time living in doorways
on the streets of London.
He was literally a
homeless urchin as a child.
He began to act on the
stage from the age of seven
and almost immediately
was recognized
as having astonishing gifts.
He worked from 1906 through
1913 for a theatrical company
in England called the
Karno Company, K-A-R-N-O.
And it was a company that put
on a certain kind of theatrical
anthology, in which
there would be skits,
comic skits and serious
skits acted out.
Sometimes when the
skits were over,
there would be song and
dance numbers, sometimes just
straight singing.
A kind of British variety
show, influenced especially
by the traditions of
the British musical.
And the Karno Company
was a traveling company.
And first, Chaplain
worked with the company
all around the British Isles.
And then, in I
think 1909 or 1910,
the Karno Company
made a triumphant tour
of the United States.
By this time, Chaplin was one
of the leading actors in this.
One of the great features of
the Karno Company performances
were pantomime performances.
And Chaplin was a particularly
brilliant pantomimist.
So he had a very
significant career.
He was already a
successful performer
on the stage in
the Karno Company
and drew on traditions
of performance.
Chaplin's father was
a popular singer.
His songs were published
and he sang in the musicals
for a certain period.
And Chaplin's mother
had visions or fantasies
of being a performer herself
and used to perform privately
to Charlie.
So Charlie was steeped
in performance,
steeped in theater.
And as a young boy,
from the age of seven
on, was already sort
of acting on stage.
Almost continuously after
the age of eight or nine,
made his living as an actor.
So as a relatively young
man, he made a trip
to the United States
with the Karno Company.
The Karno Company toured various
cities in the United States,
was a great success.
A second tour almost
immediately followed,
I think within six months.
And on that second
tour, Mack Sennett
saw Chaplain perform
and hired him away
from the Karno Company.
Saw that Chaplin had certain
gifts as a performer that
would work in the infant
medium of the movies
and hired him away.
And it was an inspired decision.
When Chaplain first joined
the Keystone Studios in '19--
I think it's 1911.
The date is in Cook.
So be careful.
My date may be a
year or two off.
But around 1911, he
joins the Karno Company.
His first few films, his
first three or four films,
he's just a performer in.
But he has an immediate
affinity for the camera as well.
And within half a
dozen films, he's
already beginning to
direct as well as to act.
And within a
relatively short time,
he gets to be in
control of every aspect
of the making of his films.
We can get some
sense of how richly
and symbiotically
the audience reacted
to the character of the
Tramp that Chaplin created
by talking in monetary
terms about the development
of his career, about the
progress of his career.
He officially joined the
Keystone Company in 1914.
He was hired in 1911 and 1912,
came over to the United States.
And from 1914 and
1915, just that
one year, he worked for
the Keystone Company
and made 35 films in
that one-year period.
He received what was then a
princely salary of $150 a week.
The final films of those 35,
the last 15 or 20 or so of them,
featured the Tramp
figure, who had now
been fully elaborated in
various adventures that
became characteristic of
Chaplin's vision of the Tramp.
And they were
unbelievably popular,
by far the most
popular shorts that
had ever been sent out of
any movie production company.
And they made Chaplain
a household name,
first in the United
States, and then fairly
quickly all over the world.
So successful were those early
films that in 1915 he was hired
away by another company, the
Essanay Company, E-S-S-A-N-A-Y.
And for another year 1915, 1916,
he worked just for the Essanay
Company.
But his salary went up
from $150 a week to $1,250
a week in one year.
And that's a gigantic--
more than a thousand dollars
a week in 1915 is an
unbelievable fortune,
of course.
He makes only 14
films in that period.
So he goes from making
35 films in a year
to making only 14 films.
And those 14 films are
more highly finished.
He spends more time with them.
We can see in this period,
we can see Chaplain learning.
We can see Chaplin enacting in
small the Fred Ott principle.
We could see Chaplin enacting
in small the principal
I talked about last
week, in which we
see him learning to develop
performance styles that
are appropriate to the camera,
appropriate to cinematic
experience, developing
techniques as a director
to emphasize certain aspects
of the Tramp's character,
experimenting with tonal
variation in his films,
experimenting with various kinds
of comic devices, some of which
he imports from his performances
with the Karno Company
and many of which he
refines and changes
because he's working
in the movies.
One famous example of this
migration from stage to screen
is a bit that Chaplain was
especially famous for when he
worked for the Karno Company.
He did a bit them,
a pantomime, called
the Inebriate Swell,
the inebriated--
the drunk aristocrat.
That's what a swell
is, a rich aristocrat,
a man about town, the
inebriated-- the drunken
aristocrat.
And it was one of the
most popular pieces
that he performed on stage
for the Karno Company.
He remade a version of
it, a very famous film.
It's one of the very few short
Chaplins where Chaplin doesn't
play the Tramp, where he's
dressed up in a tuxedo
and he plays the
inebriated swell.
And it's a film called One A.M.
And in the entire film, Chaplin
plays a man who is drunk
and who keeps encountering
objects that misunderstands.
So as an example, he comes
across a clothes tree
in his house.
And instead of hanging
his clothes on it,
he embraces it as if it's
his wife, that sort of thing.
And almost the entire
length of One A.M.
has only one performer
in it, Chaplain himself.
And he kind of
recreates and modifies
what he had done on stage
in that performance.
It is in many ways a very
brilliant performance
and shows how imaginatively the
Chaplain character can interact
with objects, a theme to
which I'll return tonight
when I talk more systematically
about Modern Times
and about certain of
Chaplin's favorite strategies
for establishing character.
So he works for the
Essanay Company.
He makes 14 films,
including in 1915 a film
called The Tramp,
fragments of which
I'm going to show
you in a few minutes.
Then he's so successful again.
And the 14 films he makes
starring the Tramp become
international--
I don't know what
to call them-- international
phenomena, best sellers.
And the Tramp becomes
the most sought after
and the most memorable
character in the movies.
So he's hired away again by the
Mutual Company, one year later.
And from 1916 to 1917, he
works for the Mutual Company,
in which he makes this time
$1 million for that year.
And he makes only eight
films in that year.
So he goes from $150 a week,
to $1,250 a week, to $1 million
a year within three years.
And each move gives him
greater creative freedom,
gives him more autonomy.
He begins to sort of
really refine his art.
And we can see the process
happening in these shorts.
In the films you're
going to see tonight,
both of the short films,
Easy Street, 1917,
and The Immigrant,
also made in 1917,
come from this Mutual period.
And I mention this to you
because they're already
in some sense
sophisticated films,
even though they're not
feature-length films.
And you can see that Chaplain
is bringing all the resources
of his narrative skills, of his
skills in creating character
to bear on those films.
They're already in some
sense sophisticated works
of narrative.
And there is an
apprentice period
that occurs earlier, which I
have just described to you.
Finally, in his career,
he moves, in 1918,
to a company called First
National, for which-- those
are the people who pay
him a million dollars.
I'm sorry.
I made a mistake.
His Mutual salary
was a mere $670,000.
He gets $1 million
when he goes to work
for First National in 1918, when
he makes, among other films,
one of my favorite Chaplin
shorts, a film in which we
see the Tramp character playing
a GI in the first World War.
It's called Shoulder Arms.
And it's a characteristic
Chaplain short,
except that now what
Charlie is doing
is contending with
the Kaiser's army.
He's fighting World War I.
In earlier films, we'd seen
him fighting ice storms.
We'd seen him fighting
against hunger.
We'd see him literally
fighting in the boxing ring
in a film called The Champion.
We'd seen him working as
an assistant to a pawn
broker in a film called
The Pawn Broker--
a whole series of jobs.
And by the time we
get to 1918, it's
almost as if the Tramp has
held virtually every job you
could imagine.
He can't hold a job for
long because he's a bum.
He's a tramp.
He's footloose.
Again, a theme to
which I'll return
when we talk about Modern
Times this evening.
And then finally,
in 1919, Chaplain
has become such a
gigantic figure,
such a international
icon, that he
joins with certain other icons,
D.W. Griffith, the greatest,
most famous director
of the silent era;
and Mary Pickford and Douglas
Fairbanks, the two most
famous actors after
Chaplin in the silent era.
The four of them get together
and they form United Artists.
And they formed it in part
to create their own company
so that they would be able to
control their artistic output.
And Chaplain, working for United
Artists, beginning in 1919,
Chaplain goes to work
on his feature films.
And he makes the great film,
the great silent features,
that are at the heart
of his achievement.
He makes The Gold Rush in
1925; a film called The Circus
in 1928, a more imperfect and
broken-back film in some way,
but full of some of his most
imaginative comic performances;
one of his great films in
1931, called City Lights.
And then finally, in
1936, the film you're
going to see tonight,
already deeply
into the sound era,
a film that remains
in some fundamental way a
silent film, Modern Times.
Chaplin then goes on, after
the sound era is over,
to make a series of
movies in the sound era.
And they all have some
modest interest for us
because they're Chaplain films.
Some images from them that
remain very famous to this day.
In fact, one of them was in
the New York Times today.
Did any of you notice it?
There was an article
about a scholar of globes,
who had found
evidence for the idea
that a particular globe
in a German museum,
which was said to have
been Hitler's globe,
was not Hitler's globe.
But in the middle
of the story, what
they-- any time a
person of a certain age
hears the word
"globe" and "Hitler,"
they think of Charlie's
film, The Great Dictator.
You're smiling.
Why?
Do you know the image?
Have you seen The
Great Dictator?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID THORBURN: What is the
image they're talking about?
AUDIENCE: Playing with a globe.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes.
There's a moment
in the film-- it's
a moment of great-- it's
not really a very good film.
And Chaplain's sound films are
mostly of historical interest,
despite what some
Chaplain buffs would say.
His great work is--
he's a silent artist.
And the sound film
caused problems for him
that he couldn't
fully adjustable to.
But every one of his
sound films has interest
and has brilliant moments.
And the one you're
remembering is
one of the most remarkable and
astonishing symbolic moments
in Chaplin's work.
Yeah.
It's an incredibly
ambitious film.
It tells us how ambitious
a figure Chaplin
was because he makes a satire
of Hitler and Mussolini
in an era when Hitler
and Mussolini are not yet
recognized for the egregious,
monstrous, evil figures
that we know them to have been.
They were taken seriously.
They had been voted into office.
Millions and millions
of people thought
they were admirable leaders.
So when Chaplain made
The Great Dictator
in '19-- what- '40
or '41, he was doing
something incredibly daring.
And he was actually
showing that he
thought the movies were an
art form capable of taking
on the largest
political subjects.
So even though there are
problems in the film,
and it's not an
absolutely great film,
not memorable artistically
in its own way,
there are moments in
it that are remarkable.
And it's also a
significant document
because it reminds us
of Chaplin's ambitions
as an artist.
Chaplin was one of the
very first filmmakers,
along with D.W.
Griffith I suppose,
to realize that the movies
had an aesthetic possibility,
latent aesthetic energies
and powers that if they were
tapped, would make the
movies the equivalent
of traditional art forms,
like theater and the novel.
And, of course, he
was right about that.
And he even made some films
that achieved that level
of seriousness and resonance.
The moment that
you're remembering,
what happens in it?
AUDIENCE: He's like
dancing with a globe.
DAVID THORBURN: Yes.
It's a moment of sort of manic
glee, in which the Hitler
character, played by Charlie
Chaplin, takes a globe out
and it's like a balloon.
And he pops it up and down.
And we see him throwing it up
and kicking it with his hat,
like that.
And it's a kind of fantasy
of world domination.
And it's supposed to show what a
ridiculous and infantile figure
this mock Hitler is.
And it is the most memorable
image from that film.
So in this article,
that really had nothing
to do with Chaplain,
there was a picture
of Charlie playing Hitler,
kicking the balloon
up and down.
And one reason that I
think it's significant,
that it's a mark of Chaplin's
greatness as an artist,
that even in his
imperfect texts,
even in the films that really
do not belong to the category,
to the most important
category of his most
lasting and valuable art,
images from those works
are still part of our
common cultural inheritance.
He's a very great artist,
the first great artist
of the movies.
And a figure who's
imaginative creations
remain vital and
alive today in a way
that very few artists
from that era remain,
similarly accessible
and important to people.
And it's a mark of the reach
of Chaplin's imagination
that this is so, of his
importance as a figure.
Well, there's much
more one could
say about the development
of his career.
But I want to cut
this short because I
want to show you the moment--
I don't mean that there's only
a single moment.
But I want to show you fragments
from the film in which we can
see Chaplin really discovering
certain aspects of what
he wants to do and also where
we can see Chaplin screwing up.
We can see Chaplin at a
stage before he becomes
the self-confident,
totally autonomous artist
he becomes relatively soon.
Can we put up fragments from
The Champ-- from the Tramp?
This is a film appropriately
called The Tramp.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And it's a fairly
characteristic Chaplin film.
But I think it's the film in
which, among other things,
Chaplin discovers that he can
marry melodrama and comedy.
It's the film in
which he discovers
that he can do effects that
are pathetic, and poignant,
and sentimental and mix
them with comedy in ways
that are interesting.
So here's a scene where
Charlie is rescuing a damsel.
And he does it in a
kind of comic way.
He's a kind of bum himself.
But he's always a kind
of chivalric figure.
Can you jump ahead?
Let's just show
the next one, Greg.
I'm just going to show
you a bad moment here.
He rescues this girl.
She turns out to be the
daughter of a farmer.
He's then hired by the
farmer in gratitude.
And then we get this bit.
And I'm showing you this
bit partly because I
want you see that it isn't
really all that funny
or that it's just kind
of easy slapstick.
I don't mean that
it's without interest.
It obviously has some interest.
But this incompetence is
inconsistent in some respects
with the coherent character that
he's going to begin to create.
It's never that
the Tramp becomes
this fully competent character.
But this kind of joke
here, look at this.
That's his foolish joke.
That trivializes him in a way.
Can you think of examples
of that in Keaton?
Remember in Cops, where, for
example, when he's riding along
in his car, he devises
that mechanism that
ends up punching the cop.
That would be an example
of a kind of-- it's a joke.
But it sort of violates
the spirit of the movie.
It seems a piece of debris that
is forced into the film, that
may have a comic moment, but
makes the film less coherent.
That kind of thing is
characteristic of the Tramp.
A bit later in The
Tramp-- I don't have time
to show you this passage--
a bit later in The Tramp,
we see Charlie confronting
the woman that he had rescued
and discovering for
the first time--
is it a long sequence, Greg?
GREG: No.
It's only a half minute.
DAVID THORBURN: Well,
put it up while I'm
talking, if you can find it.
You can see in this
sequence, which
I'll let run behind me, while
you pay attention to my words--
--and while the camera looks at
it and then comes back to me.
What you can see
happening in this sequence
is Chaplin discovering how
he can be, not just comical,
but sentimental.
How he can elicit sympathy
from his audience,
create sentimental effects.
In other words, what Charlie has
just done here in this image is
he's meeting the
girl's boyfriend.
He didn't know the
girl had a boyfriend.
He was falling in love with her.
Watch his expression here.
You see, he's very upset
by what he's learned.
In other words, this
is not a funny moment.
And this is the moment, I think,
in Chaplin's career, where
he realizes the films he's going
to make should not be thought
of as simply comedies at
all, but as something more
complicated than that,
as comedies with heart,
as comedies devoted
to character,
as comedies that are interested
in human interactions.
And that discovery tremendously
enlarged movie comedy,
tremendously enlarged the
movies more generally.
And then we can see Charlie
saying-- Charlie says goodbye.
And he writes this little sad
message and he leaves her.
So it's the moment
when pathos, sentiment,
enters Chaplin's work.
And in the films
you'll see tonight,
you'll understand why, after
he made this discovery,
he began to meld these
two elements more and more
fully together.
So this is a way of reinforcing
what I called last week,
the multiplicity principal.
What we can see is that in
those jokes with the pitchfork,
there was no multiplicity.
They were just funny
because Charlie didn't
know how to use the pitchfork.
But later moments in this
film, and in many later films,
we see Chaplain beginning
to create effects which
have more than one consequence,
more than one significance
for the audience.
One of the most remarkable
things about the chase scenes
that Charlie Chaplin
develops and begins
to perform in his
films-- and you'll
see wonderful examples
of them tonight--
is that the chase
scenes themselves
are tremendously moving.
They're tremendously comical.
They're full of comic
bits that are just
as imaginative as any comic
sequence one could ask for.
But they do something else,
in addition to amuse us.
They declare for
Charlie's character.
When Charlie runs
away from someone,
what we can see him doing
is using his intelligence,
using his improvisatory capacity
to figure out how to get away.
So that even when
he's running, he
is also expressing his nature.
And when the audience sees
the imaginative, or clever,
or daring way in which
he makes his escape
in a particular chase
sequence, they're not just
being amused by a joke.
They are also understanding
his character in a deep way.
He's defining his character,
even as he's also amusing us.
So we can feel the multiplicity
of that, the density,
the texture of that, always a
mark of superior entertainment,
always a mark, I would
say, of art itself.
Well, one way to
clarify some of this,
and especially to
clarify Chaplin's
remarkable popularity, is to
talk about the Tramp as a myth,
as a mythic figure.
And if you think
about his costume,
you'll understand
partly what I mean.
He wears a coat and
vest that are too tight
and pants and shoes
that are too big.
So the principle of
mismatch or of ambiguity
is built into his costume.
And then he carries
this cane and this hat.
Now, he shows a
kind of elegance.
But it's a kind of shabby,
down-market elegance.
But the question is, is
Charlie downwardly mobile?
Is he an aristocrat who's
fallen on hard times?
Or is he a poor person, who
has put on airs and aspires
to the world of tuxedos
and fancy clothes?
This question is never answered.
And that ambiguity
in his character
may be part of why the audience
is able to identify with him.
There's an uncertainty
about where
he belongs, a kind of
mismatch or an ambiguity
inherent in his costume.
His body itself is a source
of his mythological status.
It's small, dexterous,
energetic, incredibly graceful.
He's one of the great
acrobats and physical dancers,
physical performers,
that you'll ever see.
And in the films
you'll see tonight,
you'll see many examples
of this, including examples
of Chaplain on skates,
of Chaplain doing
the equivalent of dances,
and of his dexterousness
in situations involving running
or escape, just as powerfully
as anyone.
We'll see
dramatizations of this,
just as powerful as anyone could
ever imagine, ever hope for.
And then his face.
So his costume, his
body, and then his face
are part of the myth as well.
He has an unbelievably
expressive face.
His face is a theater in itself.
And it was Chaplain, more
than any other early director,
who explored the
implications of the closeup.
And I'll show you
some examples tonight
of the way in which
Chaplin manages
to use the closeup in silent
film for incredibly-- to do so.
And to be, at the
same time, what
we might call deeply,
incredibly eloquent,
a silence that is eloquent
because of the qualities
in his face.
And the moral
qualities of the Tramp
are also appropriately
ambiguous.
He has chivalric qualities.
He wants to defend children
and vulnerable women.
He's always a kind of
defender of the weak.
But at the same time, he's
an opportunist and also
a survivor.
And these qualities don't
fit perfectly together.
And we see both elements
in the Tramp character,
again and again.
Again, tonight, in The
Immigrant especially,
you'll see both sides of
the Chaplain character,
both his opportunistic side
and also his chivalric side.
So these qualities
created a kind
of mythic aura, a mythic
authority for Chaplin.
And there's one other thing
that contributed to the myth.
It was that there's a historical
reality to the hobo figure.
Long before Charlie
Chaplin began
to perform as a kind of
tramp figure in the movies,
they were real tramps
in the society.
And the existence of a genuine
population of homeless people--
they often rode
the rails, and they
were present actors in
most large and small cities
in the country.
The fact was there was a
population of homeless people
that the Tramp figure alluded
to and reminded the audience of.
And that also helped to
strengthen his mystic power
because it was as if the
audience was recognizing
that in some sense Charlie
was a kind of embodiment
or a symbol of this
social actuality.
So he had a kind of mythic
power that communicated itself
to his audience.
And it meant that every
repetition of a Tramp film,
which might very well go
through the same motions,
but put the Tramp in a
slightly different environment
or a slightly
different job, would
be pleasing to the audience,
some principle of repetition
and variation.
Well, finally, the
paradox of Chaplin's work.
And the paradox I want you
to think about tonight--
and we'll end with this
point-- is that Chaplin's world
is full of comedy.
It's a comedian's world,
although it's more than
just comic, as I've suggested.
But the irony of
Chaplin's world is
that the comedy is so
fundamentally based on things
that are so deeply unfunny.
Chaplin's the most deeply social
and in some ways even political
of directors.
And I'll discuss this
aspect of his work
tonight, when we talk
about Modern Times and some
of his other films.
But the crucial point here
is that Chaplain's world
is a world of elemental themes.
Virtually every
single Chaplin movie
is about hunger, aggression,
victimization, confinement.
I mean the subject matter
of Chaplin's comedy
is the furthest from comedy.
And part of his
genius, part of what
makes him such a remarkable
and important artist,
is that this immensely
unpromising material,
this disturbing and in many
ways frightening material,
dramatized sometimes with full
frightening effect-- Chaplin
often, because of
his diminutiveness,
puts himself up against
large figures, giant figures,
to emphasize his
vulnerability and smallness.
Again and again, the
substance of Chaplin's comedy
is the substance of
victimization, aggression,
misery, inequality, inequity.
In other words, the subject
matter of Chaplin's work
is the furthest from comedy.
And yet he makes enduring
comedy, enduring melodrama, out
of those unpromising materials.
That paradox about
Chaplin's world
is at the heart of his work.
And it's at the heart of
why, of all silent directors,
his very best films
remain interesting today
intrinsically, not just because
they're wonderfully interesting
artifacts.
But intrinsically because they
remain serious, valuable films.
All of the Chaplain
films you're going
to see tonight, the two
shorts and Modern Times,
fit that description, as
I hope you will agree.
See you this evening.